to safety Ridge on Sunday well this
morning we are back future Liz trust
Britain's shortest serving prime
minister has written an extraordinary
article in this morning's Sunday
Telegraph where she blames the left-wing
economic establishment for bringing her
down we will promise 3000 words it ended
up at 4 000 I guess that's inflation for
you and she's promised me back with even
more interventions in the coming weeks
which I'm sure which is inacc will be
absolutely delighted about we'll see
what our guests think of the list trust
comeback on the show this morning
so we're going to be talking to the
business secretary Grant shaps on the
program this morning we will also speak
to his opposite number the shadow
business secretary Labor's Jonathan
Reynolds meanwhile there's another part
of the public sector and Emergency
Services on the brink of a major strike
we'll be joined by the general secretary
at the far brigades Union Matt rack
and with yet more attention between the
US and China will speak to the chair of
the Foreign Affairs committee Alicia
Kearns
and there's a dark cloud hanging over
the UK's biggest police force as the Met
faces a loss of public trust we'll speak
to his Majesty's inspector of
constabulary map
[Music]
foreign
good morning well let's start today
shall we with the view from the
government being quite straight on a
little earlier I spoke to the business
secretary Grant chaps
it feels like today is all about the
return of Liz truss are you glad to see
her back well she said you know uh
written this article and obviously wants
to provide a bit of her background
thinking actually in in many ways I
think uh what she has had to say
um you know will be things that people
knew about her all along that she was
saying it when she was she was briefly
prime minister the most important thing
now is uh to get on with the things that
we describe and the current prime
minister has been very clear about his
priorities which you know really really
matter and getting inflation cut in half
will be a big priority growth in the
economy which is something which of
course Liz wanted to do herself reducing
debt uh which we think is very important
um cutting the waiting list in the NHS
stopping the small boats so all those
priorities I think of things the whole
country will get behind we'll definitely
talk about some of the priorities uh
later but you know Liz truss pictured on
the front page of the Sunday Telegraph
saying I was brought down by the
left-wing economic establishment what is
the left-wing economic establishment
well people can read the long article to
to get her version what about do you
think the left-wing I mean she describes
it doesn't she she describes it in the
article but what I was going to say is
and she says it herself the most
important thing that we can do for the
British people is make sure that the
economy is stable in particular the
inflation's falling and she says it
herself whatever the intentions the
markets weren't prepared for it and I
think she describes in the article how
um and I think it's true you've got to
deal with the fundamentals first you've
got to reduce inflation which is the
biggest tax cut that's not really what
she's saying in the article is it I mean
she sounds to me like she's basically
saying she had the right priorities and
you talk about the markets I mean I'm
assuming that's what she means by the
left-wing economic establishment you
know the 45 billion pound of unfunded
tax cuts that crashed the pound and led
to the bank of England having to make
emergency measures to stop Iran on
Pension funds I mean in a sense you'd
have to get her in the studio and ask
her I did read in the article um I
noticed she said that they hadn't
prepared the ground for these uh big tax
changes and I think the truth is and we
know this what you've got to do first is
deal with the big sort of structural
issues that deal with inflation first
um deal with the the debts you're on a
downward trajectory and and then you
look towards tax cuts everyone wants a
lower tax economy uh we still have a low
tax economy than say Germany or France
or Italy but it's really important that
we uh that we deal with the big
fundamental issues halving inflation
first for example
do you think it's a bit deluded
for her to write to ask look I think
anybody who has served in public office
has a right to put across their
arguments that's what we do as
politicians right you you you say what
you believe and you put them across
conclusion she's got a right to put
across her arguments but at the same
time if you're conservative MP you know
what's going to say in a marginal seat
but to be completely honest right now
pretty much all concept of seats are
marginal ones
you're going to be reading this with
your head and your hands aren't you all
it's doing is reminding people of the
shortest serving prime minister who not
only crashed the pound but she crashed
your poll ratings as well well as I say
people can read it and come to their own
conclusions and I mean yes
you're sort of you're sort of asking me
in a sense what I think about it and
actually I want to make sure that we we
have a really stable economic basis for
this country so things like what do you
think of the actual Liz truss article
because you're asked answering a
slightly different question there right
yeah well I was going to say what we do
know is what happened when we followed
that route without having laid the
groundwork so I completely agree with
Liz's instinct to have a lower tax
economy what we also know is if you do
that before you've dealt with inflation
and dealt with the debt then you end up
in in difficulty you can't get the
growth out of nowhere so I mean look I I
think the main thing for people to know
is Rishi sunx come in he's removed that
premium that we saw because the markets
didn't like what was going on back then
and entirely remove the additional
premium that was being applied to our
essentially our mortgage rates so we're
back to where we we should be and he's
getting on with the the difficult the
difficult job of in a world where
Putin's invaded uh a country a
neighboring country and inflation has
therefore gone up he's gone on with a
difficult job of dealing with those
things so I think rather than looking
back and I know your tempting meters
will give up a running commentary
several months ago I'm not just looking
back I mean part of the reason that I
think it is important to talk about Liz
trance is that you know there's been a
lot of briefings from her allies to say
look she wants to make a return to
politics and she said it in her article
herself that you know in the coming
months she's going to be putting out her
vision some people say that look she's
waiting in the wing she's ready to have
another crack at it I mean would you
serve in a Liz trust Shadow cabinet well
look first of all I am focused on Rishi
sunak making sure that we win the next
election by sourcing out these very
difficult problems and this is the thing
which I think is often missed in this
discussion the way this is framed often
and you think these problems that we're
only facing the United Kingdom but
actually if you look almost everywhere
else they're not they're not only facing
the United States the same issues we are
the only G7 economy with a smaller
economy than a pre-pandemic if you look
at the ifs forecast we are bottom of the
chart so one of these things where in
part depends which stat you want to look
at from which period so for example last
year we probably had according to the
IMF and the oecd the fastest growing
economy in 2022 in the G7 probably in in
2021 as well the fastest growing now
this year thank you very much right well
we we had we had a rapid contraction but
then of course we came out of the of
covid first because we of the lockdown
first because we had the uh the vaccine
which we managed to develop it still has
a smaller so so what what I mean so what
I'm trying to say is is you end up in a
situation where it depends which year
you look at to see what the bounce back
is one of the interesting things I
didn't see much reported from last
week's re-projection
which as you say rightly showed a a a
more negative position this year showed
a more positive position next year but
my main point is you know Putin involt
invades Ukraine inflation goes Sky High
because of energy prices this government
actually under this trust as it happens
but pushed through by Rishi uh sunak has
paid for about a third of people's
energy bills to try and help people
through these difficult times and we're
still doing that so people probably
don't realize when they look at this guy
high energy bills that the taxpayer the
government has stepped in is paying a
third of that now of course that's going
to have a big hit on any economy but the
point is you know rishi's said it first
of all deal with that inflation don't
feed that inflation and then make sure
you're growing the economy and make sure
you're reducing the debt cutting the NHS
waiting list that's our priority let's
talk a bit about energy bills uh shall
we because you know British gas hit the
headlines in the last few weeks because
of and expose by the times which shows
what is happening to people when
companies come in and they forcibly
install prepayment meters which
effectively means if you don't put
enough money in then your energy gets
cut off I know there was this really
moving story an undercover story where
there's a family with the kids clothes
on the radiators there was a note on the
door one of the doors to the girls
bedrooms saying no boys allowed apart
from Daddy and they went in when that
family went out and they forcibly
installed a prepayment meter what are
you going to do about it well first of
all it's absolutely disgraceful we've
already hauled in the boss of British
gas made absolutely clear he accepts
that they've got it completely wrong I
also think that the regulator this is
off gem I've had the wall pulled over
their eyes actually because I had
already made clear to them that they
needed to be making sure that the energy
providers weren't carrying out this sort
of outrageous behavior I mean literally
evolves as you described invade
somebody's home and forcibly changing
the meter to a prepayment meter that's
not right at all and unfortunately what
the regulator was doing was going back
to the Energy company and saying are you
following all the rules in the engine oh
yeah yeah don't worry that's not the way
to do this I've required a plan for this
Tuesday from the energy companies and
from left off gem which needs to include
the regulator going direct to the end
consumer and the end consumer being able
to report these things direct to them
these kind of abuses are not on I've
called for all of the energy companies
to prevent to stop this process as a
British guests have and others like OVO
had stopped it some time ago and I want
to make sure that this does not occur in
Britain in modern Britain today it's
absolutely disgraceful no one should
have their home invaded like that it's
interesting you mentioned the regulator
there 33 000 complaints to often about
prepayment meters last year are they fit
for purpose well I look I I want to I
want to make clear that off gem needs to
raise is a game on this
it cannot be acceptable simply to take
the assurances of the electricity
companies or the the power companies uh
when they when when we know that these
abuses have been taking place even
before that Times article I had set out
the energy companies and off gem that I
had serious concerns and that's before
we saw this undercover investigation and
look we have laws that prevent people
from being cut off from their
electricity there's no point me and the
government paying a third of the bill on
behalf of taxpayers so every every
homeowner it's getting about a third of
their bill paid this year because of
these Sky High Energy prices only to
have the energy companies come in and
undermine that effort so we're trying to
provide NG security for every household
and businesses in this country and we
will not have the system undermined like
this is have you done enough as well
because you talk a lot about you know
how you stepped in but you've only just
done this pretty recently this is not a
new practice this was going on last year
as well wasn't it why have you not acted
sooner yeah well I've only been of
course business and Energy Secretary for
about three months yeah
but prior to that I was going to say
we've never had a situation in this
country where the state has been
involved in helping to pay People's
Energy bills about a third of your
energy bills being paid I'm not talking
about this I'm talking about the
practice of prepayment the the two
things are connected the reason why
we're doing that and the reason why
there's been a big increase in in this
uh I would say abuse of people's homes
people being invaded to have their their
meter change is because of the high
energy costs so of course naturally this
is not an issue that was very high on
the agenda until Putin invaded Ukraine
uh and he created this spike in NG
prices so you know this has now been uh
uncovered and we are taking pretty Swift
action you'll you'll you say you're
taking Swift action um you've called in
British gas giving him a talking to
you're right into the energy companies
to give them a talking to you is there
anything you're doing other than
basically giving people talking to why
not have total ban well people people
could lose their licenses ultimately and
the reason you wouldn't want a total ban
is having to give you one simple example
my sum 21 uh lives in a in a flat in
London which she he shares um it's
actually very convenient for them to
have a prepayment me so it it you know
there are some there are situations
where you want to be able to have that
kind of flexibility so I don't think we
should be banning all prepayments no but
would you ban anyone switching to a
prepayment meeting without permission
well well first of all there is a legal
process that has to be gone through
we'll talk about the legal process I
understand there's various Hoops you
have to jump through but should you have
a total ban on people having a
prepayment meter if they don't want one
so I was going to say the legal part of
the process is important because this
can't happen without a court saying yes
you can do this so I have a bit Court's
been doing it well so the point isn't
they've just been signing them through
so as I was going to say the rest of
that is I think there's also a very
legitimate question about why thousands
of the these have been being waved
through that is supposed to be the the
check on the system and and to answer
your question more fully obviously
people need to pay their bills and so
there has to be a backstop of look what
happens
there does need to be a last case
scenario if someone can't pay that but
of course ultimately if you don't pay
your bills and people will have taken to
court that's the system we live under
right but I think ultimately there's a
legitimate question to ask about why
thousands of these warrants have been
weighed through without a proper
consider consideration on an individual
basis so I think there's plenty that's
gone wrong here and I'm absolutely going
to fix it okay
um the Sunday Times today says that
Rishi sunak is planning some tough new
immigration laws that in their words
would take Britain to the boundaries of
international law now Sky News
understands the PM is looking at Banning
people who arrive in the UK on small
boats from appealing
um is that true well so first of all
when you read those kind of lines it
makes it sound like we're talking about
all forms of immigration including
refugees I have refugees living in my
own house and ukrainians through
ukrainians and their dog living my own
house this com this country and this
government has been incredibly open and
generous to genuine refugees what we
can't have are boats arriving here with
illegal gangs and gang Masters uh
trafficking people trafficking people
here and to be impotent in in return and
so arishi is absolutely right to apply
the full force of the law to stop this
illegal trade in human misery and I
think he is absolutely right to pursue
that and I think he's right to make sure
that we can change the law something by
the way labor vote against at every
single opportunity so the question they
don't want to stop the small boats and
we do the question is is the PM looking
at Banning people arriving on small
boats from appealing against deportation
so I I think the direction here I I
hadn't seen that specific story but the
direction here is quite straightforward
if you come here via an illegal route so
you come here to claim Asylum and you
know in the first place the way you're
getting here is not legal you haven't
got an airplane you haven't got a
commercial service you've just been
trafficked illegally then if you come
here by that route then you you
shouldn't get uh rights and that I think
is quite a bit right you shouldn't you
shouldn't get rights if you're brought
if you if you consent and you come here
through illegal route what we must have
is a situation where people can come
here legally and claim Asylum but not
illegally yeah but the point is you
can't cut illegally to claim it can you
unless you are from people with specific
people who come here from Ukraine from
people come here from Afghanistan people
come here all the time and legally claim
Asylum when they get here so the
important thing is there haven't been
people traffic so to get here they
bought a ticket to get here people
trafficked and people are paying for
that trip by the way huge amounts of
money to the gang Masters it's not the
getting here free it's not them coming
here by that
for people to come here and claim a sign
legally given you have to claim asylum
in the first safe country you pass
through
um to get here which which also calls
into question why it is that that hasn't
already happened before people end up
that's different people traffic I'm just
questioning because they could already
play from legal routes for people from
countries other than those well all I'd
say is I don't think there's a country
with a bigger heart when it comes to
taking people in to say including as it
happens in my own home bringing refugees
here but you've got to have that through
legal Roots uh now next week we're going
to see nurses and ambulance workers walk
out in what will be the biggest ever NHS
strike will that put lives at risk I'm
concerned that it does if you have a
situation which is what has been
happening so far where you don't have
cooperation between the backup Services
typically the Army and uh and the people
who are striking so we've seen a
situation where the Royal College of
Nursing have very responsibly before the
strikes taken Place told the employer of
the NHS this is where we're going to be
striking and they're able to put the
emergency cover in place unfortunately
we've been seeing a situation with the
ambulance uh unions where they refuse to
provide that information that leaves the
Army who are driving the backups here in
a very difficult position a postcode
Lottery if it comes to having a heart
attack or a stroke when there's a strike
on we cannot have that situation and
that's why I'm introducing laws for
minimum safety levels you um with some
waves that strike action right and one
of the very first unions to strike were
the rail workers you were a transport
secretary it feels to me like some
people are I guess blaming you really
for the lack of resolution
um here's Mark Harper this is the
current transport secretary and he has
said what I've tried to do since I got
this job was to I met the unions I've
tried to change the tone of the
conversation so that we're coming across
as more reasonable I mean I'm pretty
sure he's having a dig at you there
because you didn't meet the unions he's
implying that you didn't come across as
reasonable and that were absolutely
certain it's not because Mark and I talk
about it and we we get on very well so I
don't think that's his case at all and
actually interestingly do you regret
return that you adopted no look let me
just answer the question interestingly
the union said if you just let us talk
to you directly rather than talking to
the employers who by the way are the
people who need to resolve this then
this whole thing could be over they've
now had months and actually by the way
two transport secretaries since me where
they have had those discussions and
they've carried on striking so the whole
thing was uh you know uh you know a
screen that they were putting up to sort
of pretend that was the reason why they
needed to strike some might say though
if you if you'd engage with the unions
and the legitimate concerns people had
about pay and inflation much earlier
then we wouldn't be in this situation
now where it feels like both sides are
totally entrenched in the possibility of
resolution across all sectors although
it's very hard to see first of all I did
meet with them it was during covert a
lot of the time but I did meet with uh
links during covid online I've got no
objection to I mean I think it's a good
idea to meet and speak the simple point
I was making is the dispute is one which
is between the unions and their
employers and they're the only people
who can resolve it and I really want to
see it results let's just say this I
really want to see it resolved you know
um we've got it's incredibly sad that
some people who are the least well off
are being hurt the most by for example
the train strikes where somebody who
maybe is a hospital Porter a cleaner who
physically has to go to the job can't
work from home those are the people who
are being hurt so I think the quicker
this is resolved the better and I very
much hope that you know employers and
unions will get around the table and if
ministers can help great all the
evidence is it you know that not been
the the show changes so far now I won't
forgive myself if I didn't ask you about
this in the interview
um on a very different note just talking
about your social media presence I just
want to have a look at something
now leveling up will be defined by
action and that's exactly what this
government is doing today hi can I get a
flat white please we're currently
inflation is about 10 I know what you're
thinking is he going to eat all of that
by himself
what if I told you this cake is actually
totally guilt-free
there has been a explosion of what I
would describe as kind of cheesy
government social media videos that I am
blaming you for for starting them off
what is going on they're guilty well
look I just think we can spend our time
like talking to the Westminster inside a
bubble actually if you send a regular
tweet that's what you do everyone will
get very excited
um or I've certainly found
um that if you produce videos which are
like more interesting I did one with
Michael Portillo uh about Great British
Railways uh I've done others with sort
of former uh uh people from for example
from Top Gear and actually you can cut
through you have millions do you think
the Prime Minister and the chancellor
trying to get in on your accent they are
yeah I've got to be honest I think
they're following might either but I
just think you know in the modern world
if you want to actually talk to the
country at large then you need to get
out there I you didn't show it there but
I also am on Tick Tock and other places
because you just get to the people who
you might want to engage with me
beauty of social media another we're out
of time but another photo that did go
variable viral was this one
um put on your Twitter accounts there
you are with Boris Johnson and as if I'm
magic
he's gone
it was a complete screw-up uh somebody
at that time which was I think 18 months
two years ago had screwed around with
the picture actually somebody with a
pixel phone which uh does that I
accidentally it was picked out the file
and said not deliberately I love Boris
Johnson I enjoyed working with them no
reason to want to do that are you going
to go around airbrushing Liz truss that
yeah
actually I actually went to see the day
that went down I took it down as soon as
I found out what happened I actually
went to see um Boris and I said to him
let's take a photo and I'm going to like
tweet it saying there's no air brushing
him out this one or something like you
know but uh
jcd release we got the photo but I
didn't post it in the end but it was a
complete scrap not deliberate at all
okay thank you very much I've got chats
anyone would believe him I'm sure and
tomorrow is expected to be the biggest
day of strikes in the history of the NHS
ambulance workers and nurses in England
will walk out once again in the long
running and increasingly bitter dispute
overpay and foreign Rescue Services are
likely to become the latest part of the
public sector to strike very soon as
well at the Farber goes union members
have voted to strike and union leaders
will hold talks with the government on
Wednesday with the fire brigades Union
general secretary Matt rack joins us now
um good to have you on the program what
do you expect to happen next week then
well we we will be meeting our employers
not the governments actually they don't
have a role directly in our pay
negotiations and in a way we're quite
pleased that they don't uh we we can
negotiate with our employers and we hope
we can resolve this distribute but I'd
like to say something about why we're
even in this position because
firefighters have voted in huge numbers
and overwhelming vote for strike action
but they don't do that lightly they've
done that because they've had 12 years
of endless attacks on their pay so that
on the basic rate of pay a competent
firefighter which more than half the
workforce are on is using the
government's preferred measure of CPI
some four thousand pounds a year worse
off than if we kept up with inflation
and you you know what no matter how much
you love your job and want to serve the
community at the end of the day people
have bills to pay rent to pay mortgage
to pay and families to look after and
people have been brought to that point
how much do firefighters get paid then
so competent firefighters on just over
32 000 pounds a year for a 42 hour week
so we're working longer than the average
working week for a basic pay our members
work permanent shifts generally most of
the overwhelming majority of whole time
Farmers work permanent shifts including
permanent weekends and so on and that's
for 32 000 pounds a year with high rates
of pension contribution for example now
you I think I'm right in saying you
rejected a payoff of five percent uh
last November what percentage are you
looking for well we started let's look
at how it's unfolded we were offered two
percent uh and I've got to say if
perhaps if our employers hadn't started
by offering two percent our members
might have might have reacted
differently I don't know uh by then uh
inflation had begun to take off so
significantly it wasn't me who rejected
five percent it was our members we put
it to a secret ballot and they voted by
79 to reject that yeah I'm not in a
position to say what would settle it
we're in discussions with our employers
and I'm not going to negotiate on scan
ITV but we we will be meeting him on
we're discussing with them this weekend
and tomorrow and we meet them on
Wednesday we hope would it be would it
be fair to say um and I I look we get
this a lot from union leaders
understandably you don't want to
negotiate live on TV
um but are you looking for a Payless to
match inflation double digits that's
effectively what you know the nurses
have given well it seems to me
personally that anything less than that
is a pay cut but that's for our members
to decide our members have to weigh up
all sorts of things going on strike is
not easy you're going on strike is a
struggle people lose money when you when
I hear government ministers talk about
Union Barons calling people out on
strike they don't understand at all the
the real difficult decisions that
workers have when they go on strike so
our members will weigh up all sorts of
things I hope that the fire service
employers will come in and improve their
offer in a way that we can put to our
members and our members will decide for
themselves so um you know what the
government would say is look if they
give all public sector workers a pay
rise that matches inflation or even you
know is higher than inflation in some
cases that
further Stokes inflation but also it's
unaffordable at a time when we are
spending more on our debt interest than
the entire education budget well first
of all there's no evidence whatsoever
the wages have caused this round of
inflation not that it calls but it will
make it worse there's no evidence that
public sector pay drives up inflation at
all it may lead to impacts on taxation
but let's look at the mess we're in it
wasn't firefighters or teachers or
nurses who caused the economic mess we
are in we see in the Press today that
Liz trust trying to redeem herself well
perhaps the conservative government
should look a bit closer to home as to
who caused the economic chaos that
working people are now being asked to
pay for
are you concerned that lives could be
put at risk if firefighters go on strike
well of course we don't underestimate
the seriousness of what we are doing and
and our members understand that but as I
say at the end of the day people have uh
families to look after in terms of
safety uh we are the government has
brought in legislation long before this
new legislation to require fire services
to put in place resilience plans as it's
described contingency arrangements and
each year they're supposed to check that
we've always been assured by ministers
and by Chief Fire officers that all
those plans are perfectly adequate so
that's their responsibility the question
about Public Safety is one that sits
with the government and with Chief Fire
officers it is their responsibility not
the responsibility of firefighters
the safety is on is is at the door of
the government and others not individual
uh firefighters but if I just want to
look at for example this is a Holland of
the West Midland fire brigades union he
said we expect fire services to depend
on the small number who choose not to
strike to provide cover during any
periods of action it goes on to say you
know there will be an agreement that
allows firefighters and control staff to
respond to Major incidents during strike
action if they wish to do so I mean it
sounds an awful lot like you are putting
you know safety on individual
firefighters we need to look at the
legal response the legal responsibility
sits with the Fire Authority and the
Chief Fire officer we have a reached
since 2002 in any dispute we've had
we've reached what's called a major
incidence agreement that allows
firefighters to return to work in cases
of majors and that's negotiated at a
national level and then applied at a
local level but Billy Holland will be
reflecting what his chief officer has
said in the West Midlands as they have
all over the country don't worry about
it and we can provide the quotes where
they have said I.E the chief officers
don't worry I've got it all in hand they
they've never spoken to us about any of
this by the way the chief officers there
will not have been negotiating with
Billy though the details of what they
have in place that's as I say a matter
for the chief I guess you know look
you're talking about the legal
responsibility and I'm sure you're
completely right you know your guy who's
very across the details I I defer to you
on it but I guess I'm just talking about
the the gut instinct that people have
you know the fear that people will have
oh my gosh the fire brigade is going on
strike am I going to be safe what if
there's a big fire what's going to
happen well Sophie the the we did not
call strikes we announced before we I'm
not talking about blame let's talk about
what point
there is a big fire what happened we
delayed calling any strikes for 10 days
to allow our employers to negotiate a
settlement we want to avoid a strike in
the first place at the re we've got to
look at why there are strikes in a key
sector's Health ambulance fire service
because 12 years of driving down workers
wages you
you've made your point you know
eloquently about you know who is to
blame for the strike in your view you
know the government the cuts people
can't get a decent living that they're
working long hours in the fire brigade
service putting all of that to one side
my question I guess is what happens if
there is a big fire do people attend if
there is a big fire and that's a major
incident and as I say we've got an
agreement that allows a return to work
in certain circumstances that's happened
in previous disputes in fact a
conservative Minister approached me
during one such incident and a return to
it was agreed that's happened in the
past and as we've seen it happen in
other sectors so we have examples of
where we have resolved those particular
sorts of threats so you're confident
that lies won't be put at risk by the
strike them the question of whether
safety is put at risk is one that sits
with the government and with three fire
officers so you can't answer that
question now I can't answer that because
I'm not involved in those discussions
okay now we'll talk to laborers Jonathan
Reynolds um directly after this
interview and I'm interested to know
what your message is to him because
labor so far has said look you know we
would get around the table with striking
workers we would try and negotiate a
settlement but they haven't given any
guidance on what kind of payoff would
they be prepared to give well I think
trade Unions would probably and Trade
union members would probably see uh want
to see labor more clearly on the side of
workers the labor parties was created by
workers organizations and you would hope
that labor MPS and labor leaders and so
on would
see the justice of our cause so I think
there's a bit of frustration there uh
nevertheless many labor MPS have
supported us and we we welcome that I
think we would want to see more clear
support that actually these disputes
need to be resolved there need to be pay
Rises you can't endlessly drive down the
wages of public sector workers and
expect public services to function and
that's the crisis we're in you've got
hundreds of thousands of workers in
health in Ambulance Service teachers are
now in the fire and rescue service
saying actually we can't go on like this
we need to be able to pay the bills at
the end of the month and nobody's doing
anything to address that while I've got
you
um an independent report into the London
Fire brigades Union found in November
some pretty awful examples of racism and
sexism in the force female firefighters
groped people having their helmets
filled with urine a Muslim firefighter
having bacon and sausages stuffed in his
pockets What's the culture alone it
should be clear that wasn't into the
London fire brigade Union that was into
the London fire brigade yes
we don't run the London so into the
London fire brigade I don't run the
London fire brigade I think that is a
shocking report and there are other
shocking reports which have been in the
media over the past couple of weeks
though the people affected by that in
most cases are members of our Union and
each year we have to end up taking for
example cases to employment tribunal on
behalf of members who've been
discriminated against bullied and
harassed there has been far little done
by Chief Fire officers Frank for 30
years in terms of recruitment
equality making sure the fire service
itself is more diverse making sure that
management teams are more diverse that's
a complete failure of the people running
the fire and rescue service and yes it
should be addressed we seek to build a
workplace which is welcoming and most
fire service workplaces are welcoming to
people from all sorts of backgrounds so
these These are horrific examples but
they're clearly not everywhere and what
we have uh We've created special
sections we have a women's section LGBT
section black members section to make
sure that the views of underrepresented
groups in the fire service are heard
within our Union I can't talk for
management structures but within our
Union they are heard and we've we've uh
attempted I was interested when you said
that there's been effectively failure of
leadership over 30 years and do you
think that they get it now or do you
think they'll actually more needs to be
done I don't know whether they get it
now because we we hear a lot of
platitudes frankly and there's a lot of
tick box exercises where people say
we've introduced a new policy I'm not
sure that just a new policy is adequate
to do this if you go back to when some
of these debates started there was joint
working with us because the vast
majority of the workforce are members of
our Union uh I've been you know 25 years
ago
doing joint seminars actually that most
of that has ended so first of all
equality teams have been cut back as
part of the cuts there has been a
retreat the the the first thing the
coalition government in 2010 did was
scrap all equality targets so there's
been a the foot taken off the gas by
central government as well in relation
to equality in the fire service it's
really interesting to talk to you thanks
very much um for coming thank you
and you're watching at safety Ridge on
Sunday a busy show with our interviews
with Grant chaps and Matt right there at
the file service they're coming on it
really does feel doesn't it like those
strikes at next week are an awful uh
long way from being resolved still to
come on the program uh this morning we
are going to be talking to a labor Chevy
business secretary Jonathan Reynolds see
what he made of that call for labor to
be more clearly on the side of workers
and a little bit later we're going to be
hearing from the man who inspects the
Met his Majesty's inspector of
constabulary Matt Paul be interested to
hear uh his take on some of those
stories around the Met police we'll also
get some immediate reaction from our
Deputy political editor Sam Coates who's
watching all of our interviews uh this
morning we'll speak to him in a little
bit I'm looking forward to hearing his
view on that uh 4 000 words from this
truss as well
[Music]
foreign
this morning at shall we I'm joined by
the party Shadow business secretary
Jonathan Reynolds thank you for being on
the program this morning and I just want
to get your reaction uh to what Matt
rack of the fire brigades Union had to
say he said look
strikes are coming we want to see a
labor party that is more clearly on the
side of workers you know this is your
opportunity to be clear what is your
take on the strikes next week would you
give workers the pay rise that they want
look my dad was a fireman for 30 years
right so I know from a personal
experience exactly what those members
that might talked about are experiencing
why they are going on strike and he's
right to say there's a very significant
mandate for that we've been clear we
have to we have to only say the
government must negotiate I can't give a
figure for any individual pay dispute
the same way the people negotiating
can't on television because that's part
of the negotiation but I would say we
are absolutely aware and have
consistently made clear that the reason
so many people are taking industrial
action is because they have seen their
living standards their their real wages
you know what they can purchase diminish
so much over the last 13 years I mean
one of the few things I agreed with in
Liz truss's uh essay that she's penned
today is the point where she says
compared to other European countries
compared to parts of America the UK has
to stagnated over the last 13 years and
living standards have fun I don't agree
with her proposals that she put forward
to meet that and I think she very
clearly made that a lot worse but we do
understand that but we've also got
Sophie a very very strong I am
discipline and making clear we believe
our plans for the economy will make it
grow faster than it has done for the
last 13 years but of course you need to
do that to give people over the long
term that the kind of improvements they
quite rightly expect I don't know if I'm
being slightly slow here but I do I just
don't understand why you can't give a
figure you said that that you know labor
can't give a figure for the same reason
that the unions can't give a figure
because they're involved in negotiation
but you're not involved in the
negotiation I don't understand why you
can't give a figure on what what pay
rise you would give to public sector
workers well you've got different issues
in different disputes I mean part of the
NHS dispute is very clearly about
workload okay let's talk about the
specific things would you give nurses a
10 pay rise but realistically the top
opening offer no we probably wouldn't be
able to meet that but we wouldn't
negotiate and fundamentally we have a
much more compelling message about those
workload problems because we've got that
plan to abolish the non-dom rule for the
super rich and therefore use that
Revenue over three billion pounds to
vastly increase the numbers of doctors
nurses midwives in the system so that
would be part of the negotiation but I
don't think if the people who are
directly involved in disputes can
understandably come on television and
give specific Figures it's not helpful
frankly for us to do but we're very
serious about understanding the burdens
people are facing and the fact the
government has to recognize that and the
big difference and you heard it there
from my opposite number grant shops is
that the government frankly rather than
want to solve these disputes they want
to use them as excuses for the poor
state of Public Services in the country
after being in power for 13 years they
want to use those disputes to say that's
why Public Services aren't working
everyone in the country knows even when
there aren't days when industrial action
is taking place whether it's the
railways or the Health Service things
are not as they should be and that is
the responsibility of the government I
think everyone would you know agree that
there is a lot of strain on public
services at the minute but it does feel
that that did give a bit of clarity
there that look you would get around the
table you'd negotiate on uh conditions
and on pay as well but 10 pay Rises that
match inflation would be unaffordable
well look the government often cites for
instance the the 1970s where you saw
essentially a series of pay negotiations
in excessive inflation as people started
to expect it and of course that leads to
the kind of spiral that ultimately
diminishes living standards even further
but let's be clear I mean the average
settlement in the private sector last
year was seven percent well below the
rate of inflation it's just that the
public sector settlement was even more
significantly behind that so I don't
think working people in this country are
being unreasonable but they do expect
their government to listen to the
pressures they were under they would
like a little bit of responsibility from
the government because let's be frank
You could argue that the last 13 years
have been one of the most disappointing
periods in the entire economic history
of the United Kingdom and I don't see
the government really being honest and
Frank about that so labor but labor
wouldn't be able to match the pay
demands of public sector workers either
well I think we can settle these
disputes fairly quickly if the
government were to stand down and give
us a chance of doing it because I think
we fundamentally understand those issues
around workload but you know we talk
about unprecedented levels of inflation
and that's right but look at grocery
inflation I mean it's 17 percent almost
for a lot of you know people when
they're going out doing their shopping
buying essential items for the household
so of course you see in those disputes
incredible levels of turnout of people
very strong feelings about it they're
simply reflecting you know the position
they're under and I think many people by
the way are looking at this and say you
know now you've got a conservative
government's been empowered now for the
same amount of time as the last Labor
government well are they better off
after 13 years of that conservative
government and for nearly everyone in
this country the answer is no look head
to the strikes next week
um big big NHS strikes nurses ambulance
workers I mean you're a parent which you
know inevitably means you rely more on
the NHS
do you look at some of the headlines
around you know NHS strikes and feel a
bit worried
well I think any family does anyone in
the country does but I've got to say I
feel worried now at the state of the NHS
every day I mean you know sometimes
we'll joke to the kids you've got to
behave you can't you know we haven't got
time to go to any under a Tory
government that's the kind of thing
we'll see in our house because we know
the pressures that it's under and I I
don't think sometimes when the
government tries to cite
you know the pressures of of days when
just relaxing is taking place is the
worry to families that they themselves
are aware of just what kind of pressure
and concerns there are out there every
day because of the state of Public
Services under their watch um I want to
ask you a little bit about the other
story I was talking to Grant chaps about
which is the uh forcible installation of
prepayment meters obviously a lot of
people really struggling with their
energy bills this uh winter and Mr chaps
was pretty scathing about off-gem he
said that they'd had the wool pulled
over their eyes that they need to raise
their game is he right well I think the
regulator's got some points to answer
here but I wouldn't mind a bit of
leadership and accountability from the
government as well I mean this was first
raised in Parliament Before Christmas
three weeks ago labor called for an
outright ban on the process till this
was reviewed it was clearly it's a
national Scandal this is no question of
there you skewered grant shops
immediately by the fact that he might
have said it's a disgrace but he wasn't
saying he was going to stop it he didn't
say that he's going to call for a ban
and insist that this isn't happening
whilst this is looked into the process
here is deeply flawed there is no clear
definition of where this should happen
What Would We constitute as vulnerable
how should debt be treated in that and
clearly what's been happening with the
oversight in the courts of this is a
huge problem as well so we want an
outright ban whilst this process is
looked at again in some clear rules are
put in place and I think the fact that
the the Secretary of State hasn't been
able to say that this morning and that
hundreds of people maybe thousands have
had this done to them in the three weeks
since we called for that ban he's got to
be willing to accept responsibility for
that at the same time though um the
point that Grant chaps was making was
look there does have to be some kind of
something has to happen if someone just
doesn't pay their energy bill I mean do
you accept that yeah of course if
someone's going to pay the bill I mean
that's absolutely right but he tried to
conflate the process of having a
prepayment beta which actually some
people do want they like to control
their their energy bills in that way he
tried to conflate that with the forced
imposition of a prepayment meter often
with the law being broken and that is
something completely different the
government should be incredibly strong
on that they're not being strong enough
because there are no circumstances in
which that should happen I've got to ask
about that big story of the day I mean
you touched on it earlier Liz truss come
back what's your reaction to a piece in
the Sunday telegram just every week will
there ever be a conservative willing to
take responsibility for their own
actions I mean Liz truss had to stand
down because her policies were
incoherent and unsustainable and the
idea she's been brought down by a
left-wing economic establishment which
has been brought down by straightforward
economics if you want to borrow money as
she did and people don't think your
plans mean you can pay it back well
they're not going to lend you that money
I say the one thing she's writer on it
is the poor record of the government on
the economy there has been stagnation
there has been a diminishing of living
standards but you don't do that by
seeking to borrow a huge amount of money
for tax cuts for the well-off and the
idea that you know people in the city
who had no confidence in her and people
making those trades that led to the huge
pressures of the economy being crashed
the idea that they are somehow part of a
left-wing conspiracy
this is really to me about the the
conservative party
there's a lot of people want Boris
Johnson back in the conservative party
list trust clearly feels that she would
seek to make a comeback herself and I
think the biggest danger to the country
would be a fifth term of conservative
government where frankly all these
characters would seek to make a comeback
themselves do you think that Richard
Cena is a better prime minister than
listras oh I think
there has been arguably no worse prime
minister than Liz trust and I don't say
that to be to be mean but I mean 49 days
and the record she had and ultimately
you know politics it's about people and
there are many people in this country
paying higher mortgage rates as a result
of her actions and that's had a huge
impact on would do any time but in a
cost of living crisis it is but I think
fundamentally you cannot simply judge a
prime minister if they're better than
the last absolutely treadful one you've
got to judge them on are they meeting
the challenges the country faces Rishi
Sonic isn't I don't think he's in
control of the conservative party I
think he's a weak prime minister and I
think the big change we need will only
come to a general election and ourselves
having the chance to put the case for a
labor government no surprise there that
the answer is the labor government and
thank you very much for your opinion on
that uh Jonathan Reynolds and thanks for
being in the studio this morning
well the as usual to take we'll follow
this program just after 9 30. so that's
our chance to analyze today's interviews
talk through some news lines with our
Deputy participator uh Sam uh coats but
we can get a quick take from Sam now on
what has stood out to him this morning
um look Sam we've had all sorts of uh
discussion this morning about you know
energy bills or whether it's small boats
but I just want to talk to you about Liz
truss what what is the reaction to the
Liz truss comeback
well it's fascinating isn't it safely
the whole of Westminster is digesting
the 4 000 words published the Sunday
Telegraph this morning uh where Liz
trust for the first time reflects on the
44 days that she had in power before she
announced her resignation and we were
always going to be in line with a little
bit of revisionism we were always going
to be uh heading to a little bit of
self-justification whenever Liz trust
made her first intervention but I
suppose reading the whole thing what I
wasn't expecting was just how much
bluntly the whole thing is an attack on
Rishi sunac because although he's not
targeted by name in the piece when you
go through it the attack on the drift to
higher taxes which is exactly what he's
had to do since coming into office
whether it's the left-winning economic
establishment which appears to wrap up
many of those institutions that Richie
sunax says are important like the office
for Budget responsibility the whole
framing of it and the the way that she
needles her successor because she says
she got a mandate I she was voted for by
the Tory members of course we all know
that he wasn't now she claims that she
was ousted by this so-called left-wing
establishment that's not true she was
ousted by the chairman of the 1922
committee Graham Brady who came to see
her when the chaos got too much but one
other thought Sophie this morning you
had Grant chaps on responding for the
government Now Grant chat hasn't held
back in the past about Liz truss he's
called her tinnit other Tories this
morning uh saying that it's like a bull
in a tree she's like a bull in a china
shop blaming the China for getting
broken but Grant shaft was quite
moderate in his tone why well despite
all of the implied criticism of the
current prime minister this is not a
government that feels it can pick a
fight with Liz truss and her acolyte at
this point that tells you a lot about
the current Tory Mead uh yeah it
certainly does doesn't it sound I will
have more from Sam after the May main
program that will be at 9 30.
now it's the most important Global
relationship and it's not going well
because tensions have been rising
between the U.S and China for many years
now and this week's growing row over a
supposed Chinese spy balloon that flew
over America has now been shot down is
really not helping the big fear of
course is a China Chinese invasion of
Taiwan in coming years and how the US
LED West would respond well we can talk
now to the concept of MP Alessia Kent
who is the chair of the Foreign Affairs
committee and joins us now thanks so
much for being uh with us today and so I
want to talk about this spy balloon
China says oh look it's just monitoring
the weather is that at all credible
no I don't think it is I mean the
American government made clear they see
this to be an intelligence capability
it's the size of three buses it was
flying at sixty thousand feet high
that's not really where you normally get
your weather detail from and also
they've said that this is part of a
pattern where they have seen this
happening time and time again
um so I think there's no question that
this was definitely intelligence
capability now they've shot it down the
US will be able to work out exactly what
intelligence capabilities it had on
board
you know it almost sounds like something
out of a spy novel doesn't it like you
know like a spy balloon you know going
over at the United States there's been
American TV channels that have been put
on balloon watch but you know despite
the kind of gimmicks if you like this is
actually quite serious right
it is serious but I do think it's
important we don't take it out
proportion what it confirms is that
China has a real and meaningful interest
in our capabilities our ability to track
such items but also what it wants to see
on the ground America has nuclear
facilities in Montana for example but we
do have far bigger concerns when it
comes to China I think what it will do
is have for the first time a realization
amongst the American public you know
they were literally sat at home and
could see it outside their bedroom
window that they are being spied on but
actually every day many of us are
walking around with technology such as
Tick Tock in our pockets or Hikvision
cameras and our streets that are also
recording us recording how we walk how
we talk our data our networks our
friends our allies and we know these
details are being sent back to China as
well so whilst it is important actually
there are more meaningful things we
should be concerned about but for the US
what's really useful about this and
blinkum is right to cancel his visit is
that going into this visit the China
would have felt that it was in a
slightly Superior negotiating position
because of the Pelosi visit Taiwan now
actually China will need to show willing
it will need to show a meaningful effort
to bring China back on board and for the
U.S that's a really helpful opportunity
to rebalance the Diplomatic kind of
cards on the table
just want to pick up on what you're
talking about uh with Tick Tock because
it always blows my mind when I look at
you know the number of people who use
tick tock I mean I'm one of them right
you know you use the sort of videos are
we being a bit Sophie get off it stop it
can we be naive are we I'm worried now
we are we are being naive
um so look you know Tick Tock gave
evidence to my committee where they said
that there was no way that individuals
working in China could get access to the
data of Britain's but what we've now
seen is that people working in China for
tick tock hacked into European data so
they could track down the source of a
journalist because what Tick Tock does
is it gives away the data that makes you
most vulnerable who are you friends with
what are your interests what are the
interests you have that you may not want
publicly disclosed who having private
conversations with the locations you go
to there's a reason why China has this
app there's a reason why they're buying
up gay dating apps our data is a key
vulnerability and China is building a
tech totalitarian state on the back of
our data so we have to get far more
serious about protecting ourselves and
yes whilst balloons are an important
diplomatic Spike an opportunity to have
this conversation our bigger concerns
are this data penetration pathway
dependency that China is creating on
Chinese companies uh the way in which
they're intimidating those who sought
refuge in the UK and around the world
these are the bigger concerns that we
should be focused on so that's your
genuine advice then delete tick tock
from your phone
without question I don't have it on my
phone and actually it's fascinating how
often you speak to people and they go
I'm going home tonight to have a serious
conversation with my children it is not
worth having that vulnerability on your
phone and it is the ultimate data source
for anyone with hostile efforts and the
fact is now this isn't just me saying
I'm worried delete it we have evidence
that Tick Tock has been used to track
down sources for journalists everyone
should be concerned about that you know
it feels doesn't it that there's been a
lot of very correct and right focus on
Russia
um because the war in Ukraine and the
activities of Putin but do you think
that perhaps the world has slightly
taken its eye off the ball when it comes
to China
so I think over the last two decades
we've been focused on the threats from
terrorists who behave like States and
unfortunately whilst we actually need to
be looking at the States from States who
behave like terrorists now the issue is
I don't want to criticize too much the
kind of golden era of relations with
China because you can understand why
politicians around the world felt that
was the right approach but whilst they
were investing in those positive
relationships they should have been
planning to fail where they didn't plan
to fail we are now vulnerable so we need
to spend the next 20 to 40 years
focusing on resilience how we make
ourselves protected at home and every
single part of our society now that
doesn't lessen the threat from China and
I am really worried about what's going
to happen in a few weeks before tanks
arrive I'm very worried about Putin's
Mass mobilization however China is a
long-term strategic threat but it
requires significant effort from
government in order to make us resilient
and now while I've got you it's
fascinating to talk to you about um
Foreign Affairs but I have to ask you
about this article by Liz truss is about
4 000 words in the Sunday Telegraph she
blames the left-wing economic
establishment for her downfall she
blames conservative MPS for not
respecting her mandate she blames her
off Communications strategy the office
for Budget responsibility you know the
concept of party polls tanked under her
leadership I just want to know what was
your reaction when you first read uh Liz
trussen's words
so I think uh the best and polite way of
saying it would be that
Recollections do vary
um however fundamentally the markets are
not left they are not woke uh unfunded
promises are not tenable and actually
ultimately what ended listro's
Premiership was inability to manage the
party number 10 telling the minister of
the dispatch box one thing while telling
the whips another on a rather crucial
vote it was that mismanagement of the
party that is why MPS no longer had
trust in Liz trust anymore and that is
why her Premiership ended
it feels like there's a couple of
backseat drivers in the conservative
party at the minute Liz truss and
planning her comeback with more
interventions in the coming week we had
Boris Johnson of course giving an
interview earlier this week as well is
it helpful to the current man in the job
look I think um all former Prime
Ministers as back benches have every
right to call for things to try and
shape policy but I think Theresa May has
really set the standard of someone who
came back in put their head down has
worked really hard recognizes that their
voice has a real strength to it to use
it at the right times in the right way
and I think they should model themselves
on her
okay um thank you very much indeed
Alessia Ken's uh their chair of the
Foreign Affairs uh select committee
there thank you
thanks Sophie
I might have to go and delete tick tock
uh off my phone after that interview now
on another uh issue it's hard to think
of a time when the standing of the
country's largest and most important
police force has been lower another
serial sexual predator who committed
scores of rapes as a serving author is
behind bars with hundreds more
investigations underway and of course
all of that following the murder of
Sarah everard and evidence of a culture
of misogyny and discrimination now the
new boss of the Met says he's changing
the force and the organization that
inspects it is reviewing to see if
progress is happening and that part is
his Majesty's inspector of constable who
joins us now thanks so much for being on
the show I've been really looking
forward to interviewing you frankly now
you just talk through a bit what you do
because you independently assess
effectively don't you the efficiency and
effectiveness of the police in the
public interest that's right I mean what
we don't do is individual complaints and
individual individual things that go
wrong we're more interested in systemic
matters whether the police are effective
whether they're efficient whether the
public are getting the right service and
what is your assessment of that right
now then for the met in particular uh
it's in a bad place and we all know that
is well documented that public trust in
the match is at a low ebb and we've got
the met in quote special measures as it
sometimes calls so I think there's a
widespread recognition that there's an
awful lot to be done what
in the past I've described it as
complacent as arrogant as defensive and
I think there's been a reluctance to
accept the scale of the the problems and
it's hit some lower level leadership
stuff it's basic standards sometimes and
it's a culture across the met and
perhaps wider policing as well that
isn't where it ought to be of course you
you're not commenting on individual
cases rightly and but you know I I you
know just to reflect on what we've seen
you know when cousins are serving police
officer murdering server everard David
Carrick another serving police officer
emitting 71 sex offenders serving police
officers taking pictures of the bodies
of two murdered sisters sharing them on
WhatsApp
um it's just it's extraordinary I kind
of feel like in any other organization
they just clear out the leadership team
like the heads would go well they have
got a new commissioner and a new top
team uh I think under the under Mark
Rowley who's taken over and his
leadership team around him it does feel
different I think they've smelt the
coffee they understand that they can't
any longer sort of write this off as a
few bad apples it's something much more
endemic than that uh they've got a long
way to go however this is not something
that you're going to turn around
overnight there's 42 000 people in the
met and what they've got to get to is
just every one of those people behaving
at all times in a way that the public
could have a right to expect now the
police are the public and the public of
the police and this is this sort of
saying that goes way back uh but we
should I think we're entitled to hold
the police to a to a higher standard
than the general public and and so
particularly in the last few months I've
been inspecting on vetting and who gets
in and misconduct procedures and they're
not tight enough it's too easy for the
wrong people to join the police and
we've made lots and lots of
recommendations that if enacted should
start to turn things around yeah on
vetting I was interested you said
recently your analysis showed around one
in ten officers should never have made
it through betting well that was one in
turn of the cases we looked at which
wasn't a random sample okay but it still
adds up to hundreds of people who have
joined the police in the last three
years that we don't think should have
and what just can you just explain what
we mean is that because they because
they've had prior convict
uh yeah it's all of that it's prior
convictions it's linked with criminals
that are too close and not really
explained uh it's not being entirely
honest on their application it's a whole
series of things like that that we
looked at and just said this person
shouldn't have joined and these are
clear red flags right this is not giving
like a bit of a shaky answer in an
interview that's the big way of playing
yeah big red flags now what there
shouldn't be is a zero tolerance
approach to anybody that's got any
blemish on their record uh shouldn't
automatically be disbarred from being a
police officer that just wouldn't be
fair but where there is a question where
there is doubt there should be measures
put in place to monitor these people to
keep a closer eye on them and that's not
happening either I've got to ask you
um this has been going on for a while
have you guys been doing your jobs
properly as well you know you're
supposed to be inspecting the police why
hasn't all this been raised we're not a
regulator we're an inspector and we've
been saying this for years and years and
years I think what happened last year
after the the Wayne cousins murder is
the Home Secretary then got us to look
specifically at the Mets counter
corruption vetting across policing to
tie up some of these issues now the
carrot case came out after we'd done
this inspection but if you look at our
recommendations the majority of them
were very pertinent to to the sort of
things that went wrong in Carrick so I
am quietly confident now that if all the
recommendations get enacted we're going
to change and and sweller brave men are
now commissioned me to come back to her
in April and see how all the police
forces around the country are getting on
with enacting those recommendations so
so there is a kind of weight of effort
behind this and a recognition that has
gone on too far and it's got to change
interesting you said you had been
plugging this for a while who hasn't
been listening to you is it previous
home secretaries is it the police what
no I don't think you blame an individual
this is systemic across policing I think
policing is challenge it's got a lot to
do we're always challenging the police
what their priorities are but I think
the whole idea of just how important it
is for policing that the wrong the wrong
people don't get in and the wrong people
don't stay in has not has not quite been
recognized as being as important as it
is yeah
important is public come from the police
and I'm thinking you know particularly
about women and particularly women who
are reporting sexual crimes to the
police as well and you know if you look
at the statistics you know maybe they're
right to not have confidence I think
it's around one percent of reported
rapes uh and in a conviction I mean has
very effectively been decriminalized I
think when our report we look
specifically at police misconduct
Through The Eyes of uh of women serving
and policing and while there are plenty
of women who've had great careers and
gone to the top of policing most of them
if not all of them have had to endure
some completely unacceptable behavior on
the way there so I'm not talking about
you know
slightly rivaled comments I'm talking
about sexual assault in many cases
totally inappropriate behavior in the
workplace my fellow officers my fellow
officers and then being reluctant to
report it because you think you'll be
the person that's then stigmatized in
some way as a result so the culture of
misogyny within policing is something
that is there it's real and it's
absolutely got to be dealt with it's
really concerning as well isn't it
because you know if people are going to
the police for help with you know the
most sensitive things the things that
you know people feel ruin their lives
frankly and you're saying that you can't
really
necessarily trust that the person you're
dealing with is not the misogynist I
mean I think I think my my message to
the public generally would be in general
you should trust the police what I think
we're aiming for here uh is a situation
where there's it's an automatic we're
automatically assuming that we can trust
the police without having to ask these
questions I think there's a long way to
go before we're there I'm interested to
know your thoughts as well on the London
at fire brigade I know that you look at
fire Services as well and independent
report in November finding some pretty
awful examples of racism sexism and we
did speak to the uh Union Leader at the
London Fire brigades uh Union uh as well
and he was saying look there is a
failure of leadership and we've been
flagging it for a while as well the
union and they're not doing enough uh
well
many of the problems with the London
fire brigade are mirrored in the mat
we've also actually got the London fire
brigade in quote special measures
largely as a result of of a really
unpleasant culture that's highlighted in
report you refer to so we get that I
think fire service is like police have
got a long way to go to reform and be
the sort of workplace that I think the
public has a right to expect and they're
a long way from it okay thank you so
much for being on the program it's been
really interesting uh and thank you for
speaking so frankly about some of the
issues you see in the police and also
the fabricate
foreign
just before we go a quick reminder of
our weekly podcast if you scan the QR
code on your screen right now you can
find the safety Ridge on Sunday podcast
And subscribe so it's in your feed every
week There's highlights of all of the
best interviews and post-match Analysis
and a bit of an insight into how we put
the program together now today I'm quite
looking forward to it because we are
joined by Camilla Turner now she is the
person who has her byline on that 4 000
word article by Liz truss so I'm very
interested to see what Camilla Turner of
the telegraph has to say and as usual uh
by our editor it's called Beasley I'm
always interested to know what school
has to say of course
um you can find it and subscribe
wherever you get your podcast just
search for Sophie Ridge on Sunday it
should be available later today
well that's it for this week's program
in a moment after the break we're going
to be talking to Sam Coates running
through today's interviews having a bit
of a chat about what we learned so don't
go anywhere
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
's interviews with a bit of analysis at
from Sky's Deputy political editor at
Sam Coates as well and I have to say it
was a really interesting morning coming
in to work this morning to be hit by 4
000 words to read before the show so
it's lucky I got in early because this
really I think kind of set the tone for
some of the political debate today we
could bring Sam in at this point shall
we so Liz trust the comeback I mean we
knew it was coming didn't we there's
been lots of trailing over the last few
days about the fact that the former
prime minister wanted to make a big
intervention and here we have it what
was your sort of main takeaway
well Sophie I mean
if I'm being completely honest it just
makes your head hurt reading it because
to call it revisionism is he is polite
um the the way in which Liz truss has
decided now to effectively recast what
happened in her favor she was the
shortest serving prime minister uh in
British history uh the front page of the
Metro the next day after she left called
her the worst prime minister uh in uh
the UK's history she left an economic
Legacy that saw mortgage rates higher as
a result of the decisions that she took
and this is essentially a piece of 4 000
word not only self-justification but
also attack on the man that took over
from her
um but but for me some of the most
interesting passages uh her recasting of
what happened in key debates during her
period in power and and if you look at
the headline that's been put on it the
hit the Sunday Telegraph has chose to
chosen to focus on the pessimism of the
What's called the left-wing economic
establishment in those trusses view
essentially the treasury and the office
for Budget responsibilities are the two
kind of great big kind of civil servant
uh institutions at the heart of our
economic system and Liz truss's argument
is that these institutions are
inherently pessimistic they don't
believe enough in bold growth measures
uh and also essentially failed her by
failing to point out that there was a
great big problem with these Pension
funds uh that has existed since the
early 2000s but they didn't warn her uh
that they could be as it were Disturbed
uh that there could be pressure on the
pension system as a result of the
decisions that she was taking and that
shows that these institutions are flawed
and and I can quite understand that if
there are some people sitting in the
treasury today going well that's just
baloney because what happened as far as
I understood all the way along
is that people all across government
were very clearly advising Liz truss and
quasi-quarting not to embark on what's
cutely now called the mini budget that
extraordinary Bonanza of spending and
borrowing that we got in early September
don't do it because we might not be able
to afford it to as a country and that's
going to push up follow-up boring cross
costs and that's going to have a huge
impact on everyone they were warned they
were warned and ultimately not least
because the First Act of the former
Chancellor quasi-quarting was to sack
the lead civil servant in the treasury
and the message came down we're not
interested in listening to your
objections Liz trust just ignored the
treasury so far from this being the
treasury in the left-wing kind of
economic establishments fault um by the
way it's quite hard to really
characterize markets as left-wing as she
appears to do in this article she
ignored them all the way along because
she sort of didn't believe in what they
were saying for all the reasons so she
sets out in that article pressed ahead
and then there were The Economic
Consequences that were that were warned
about and and that's just not the way
that she chooses to tell it and that's
the core of the argument that she makes
that effectively she says she was let
down by these institutions I think the
truth was they warned her and she
ignored them yeah it feels like there's
two slightly contradictory things that
she's trying to say at the same time
number one that she wasn't warned enough
about what would happen if she enacted
her plan and secondly that they didn't
buy into her plan enough either because
of the left-wing economic consensus I'm
not totally sure how both of these
things can be right I just quickly
um I just want to point out the mug
behind Sam in Liz we trust great bit of
uh background I'm sure that's completely
um
there we go
excellent bit of prop management at this
morning sound I really enjoy that and
before we go back to Sam I just want to
listen a little bit to that interview
with the business secretary uh Grant
chaps because one thing that jumped out
to me from the Liz trust piece was that
she said I will expand upon the lessons
that I've learned in the coming weeks
and months which I think really is
perhaps something that will send a
shiver down the spine of people in which
you see next uh Downing Street and also
perhaps explains why people like Grant
chaps aren't exactly going in two-footed
against Liz truss because they're a
little bit worried about what she might
have to say in future let's have a
listen to Grant shops
I think anybody who has served uh in in
public office has a right to put across
their arguments that's what we do as
politicians right you you you say what
you believe and you put them across what
we do know is what happened when we
followed that route without having laid
the groundwork so I completely agree
with Liz's instinct to have a lower tax
economy what we also know is if you do
that before you've dealt with inflation
and dealt with the debt then you end up
in in difficulty you can't get the
growth out of nowhere so I mean look I
think the main thing for people to know
is Rishi sunx come in he's removed that
premium that we saw because the markets
didn't like what was going on back then
uh well let's get uh sounds take uh
shall we you can bring him back uh from
his South London uh broadcasting studio
um Sam what what did you make of the
grant chants response
well it was quite
tepid wasn't it in terms of hitting back
and defending uh uh or really attacking
Liz truss in the way that she attacked
uh the Prime Minister now I just want to
rewind to early October Sophie guess
which prominent conservative was at the
Forefront of laying in to Liz truss and
her Premiership well it was only Grant
chaps who um was excluded from Grand
chapters from Liz truss's cabinet on the
grounds that Liz trustworthy picked the
wrong team by battling Richie soon like
in the summer Leadership content and a
contest and um Grant chaps turned up to
Tory conference in
um was it Manchester uh in Birmingham
sorry and basically spent the entirety
of that conference slugging it out with
Liz truss in the TV studios uh pointing
out the problems with the economic plan
that she had embarked on and really um
was not in any way tepid or timid about
attacking her but this is the same guy
that sort of has very much this morning
done on the one hand on the other uh
attempt to deal with Liz trust and and
that's because the fishes the divisions
that we talk about every week on this
slot inside the conservative party can't
go away
um and and are very much still there and
and the job I think of number 10 at this
difficult moment for them is to try and
not inflame the irritation of Tory
colleagues many of whom um through the
uh sort of defenestration of Liz truss
lost their jobs backed the wrong person
still feels sore
um and yet need to be relied upon for
difficult decisions for votes in the
House of Commons whether it's on the
Northern Ireland protocol making sure
they don't kick off too much when Boris
Johnson faces the Privileges committee
uh also having to deal with stuff around
the European Convention of Human Rights
and not causing too much of a Revolt
around that so the mood isn't it isn't
possible in Tory circles for number 10
to come out swinging perhaps as
aggressive as they would like against
Liz truss she's got more uh fuel in the
can she's done an interview which is
actually going to be a video interview
with The Spectator uh magazine that's
going to be released at five o'clock
tomorrow so that'll be the first time
where journalists please go to The
Spectator Katie balls is going to put
questions to Liz truss about exactly
what what got on because the Sunday
Telegraph asked obviously no opportunity
to challenge what Liz trust says in that
she just presents uh her case so Katie
bulls will be doing that tomorrow we'll
get to see on camera Liz truss's
reaction uh and uh response to the
questions I think we've all got so
there's a lot left but Liz trust still
has some fans in the Tory party and
there are a lot of fans of cutting taxes
and perhaps taking on some of the
economic establishment so this isn't a
fight that number 10 can risk having too
aggressively yeah it certainly when as
you say there is clearly more to come it
feels quite choreographed doesn't it and
one person who wasn't holding back
though unlike one shot was the shadow
business secretary Jonathan Reynolds he
really went in on the former prime
minister let's have a listen to Labor's
take
will there ever be a conservative
willing to take responsibility for their
own actions I mean Liz truss had to
stand down because her policies were
incoherent and unsustainable and the
idea she's been brought down by a
left-wing economic establishment which
has been brought down by straightforward
economics if you want to borrow money as
she did and people don't think your
plans mean you can pay it back well
they're not going to lend you that money
I say the one thing she is right on it
is the poor record of the government on
the economy there has been stagnation
there has been a diminishing of living
standards but you don't do that by
seeking to borrow a huge amount of money
for tax cuts for the well-off
uh Jonathan Reynolds there I think he
also described Liz trust as possibly the
worst prime minister we've ever had
which is quite a statement I mean I
guess from Labor's perspective this is
all quite good right reminding voters of
the time of the mini budget when
everything went wrong and also about the
current divisions and the conservative
party that you've been discussing
oh it's a complete gift for labor in
every way uh we've got uh Liz trust not
forgotten but now back in the headlights
promising this and more you've got the
Specter of Liz truss and Boris Johnson
perhaps even teaming up over things like
opposition to forthcoming deal on the
Northern Ireland protocol uh you've got
one of the worst periods in Britain's
modern economic history being picked
over to Labor's benefit and you've got
clear signs that number 10 just holding
back slightly in the way that it's
responding and Tory MPS like the one you
were talking to are clearly angry and in
despair at the return of Liz truss uh
stealing all the headlines look Sophie
again we sit here every week and we've
been asking for several weeks when is
Rishi sinat's government going to be
able to get on the front foot with its
own agenda there are plans underway to
try and reset the debate around
migration tough new plans possibly
taking on the European
stress ball courts when it comes to
pushing the boundaries to stop people
being able to Acclaim asylum in this
country you were talking to Grant chaps
about that but it was sort of item
number three or so in the interview last
week it was all about Nadeem zahawi's
resignation we've still got the
unfinished business potentially of debt
to prime minister Dominic Robb and
what's happening with those uh possibly
24 bullying allegations we are now in
February which is soon at came in right
at the start of November hasn't really
had a great deal of time where he's been
able to set the agenda in the way that
he wants the only claim that Rishi seen
that really was making on the first
hundred days is that he managed to lower
the temperature economically and undo
some of the damage that Liz trust did to
the Tories economic competence
reputation and here we are picking
through the bones of that with a very
significant figure suggesting that
Richie sunac was wrong even to do that
so it's very very painful people there
is a tone in Liz truss's article frankly
of extraordinary self-pity that
everybody was against her but I also
detected tone amongst some of those
around Richie sunac of self-pity there
as well as they have to deal with all
the problems caused by their
predecessors it's just a very miserable
Place being in the conservative party at
the moment everybody feeling sorry for
themselves I'm just not quite sure
that's where the public view it yeah it
does feel like that actually doesn't it
whenever you can talk to conservative
MPS they do have this gloominess this
kind of existential like despair about
the direction of their party whatever
faction they're from in whatever
Direction they think the party should be
going in I mean one of those I guess was
Alicia Cairns now I was speaking to her
it was a fascinating to be actually
about U.S China relationships about
Chinese influence in the UK but I did
also ask her about Liz truss she said
that former Prime Ministers should model
themselves on Theresa May
all former Prime Ministers as back
benches have every right to call for
things to try and shape policy but I
think Theresa May has really set the
standard of someone who came back in put
their head down has worked really hard
recognizes that their voice has a real
strength to it to use it at the right
times in the right way and I think they
should model themselves on her
they should be modeled on Theresa May
Sam
well Teresa may of course play the big
role ousting predict particularly Boris
Johnson and then uh didn't seem to be a
particular fan of Liz truss perhaps
Court's controversy with the
extraordinary amount of outside earnings
uh that she makes including giving
speeches in Saudi Arabia so it's not a
universally adored model of being an
ex-prime Minister but Alicia Keynes
always a fascinating voice to listen to
She Doesn't pull her punches as an
important select committee uh chairwoman
and basically I suspect voicing the kind
of frustration that many in the
conservative party uh feel this morning
interview and I was really struck as
well because she literally ordered me to
get off Tick Tock she was like look
don't trust Tick Tock
um it's a Chinese owned uh organization
you should be very worried about it that
would unequivocally be my advice are you
on Tick Tock Sam are you going to delete
it
uh I I don't I I I'm not on Tick Tock
things by me might be put on Tick Tock
by others um I it's a weird one
um I don't like Tick Tock because of the
way it sort of treats the news as it
were and everything becomes a bit more
of a sort of arm of entertainment rather
than uh rather than anything else half
the time you seem to be expected to
dance and that's not something really
that you want to see me do but the
concerns about security have been well
uh I think picked over in the last few
months and years in America the debate
is incredibly aggressive around China
whether or not Chinese social media acts
are safe for people uh to use and it
looks like there is a wing of the
conservative party that's pushing that
debate here and Parliament was going to
have a tick tock account that now has
been scrapped in light of some of the uh
arguments and bands of UK MPS from being
able to go to China and I think that
this debate is going to continue to go
in this direction you only have to look
at the temperature around that debate in
America about the Chinese balloon they
say a weather balloon the USA a spy
bullying that's just been shot down over
the weekend to know that UK China
relations are in a U.S China relations
are in a difficult place and if as
Alicia Kern says the Chinese government
effectively can mine data from
individuals from apps like Tick Tock I
think a lot of people find that quite
serious interesting stuff and just to
end Sam I wondered if we could get a bit
of a thought bit of analysis from you
about you know the sort of state of the
government right now where she seen
Exposition you know you've had this
intervention from Liz trust that you
rightly say is effectively an attack on
the current man in the job and the
nervousness around how to deal with that
from the common cabinet because he's got
all of these things that he needs to get
through how precarious do you think his
position is
I've got one massive question about
Richardson at government which is
when push tough comes to shove can it
actually get anything done right it has
succeeded in calming the economic
terminal that we were talking about
later actually to be fair borrowing
costs on mortgages are back where they
were before the mini budget so that's
quite a big success but the question now
is can Richie sooner actually do
anything proactive because he doesn't
have a mandate from the members or it is
a mandate from the public stretches back
to Boris Johnson's election win he's
trying to do a couple of massive
controversial things when it comes to
strike where legislation possibly
dealing with the Northern Ireland
protocol on brexit and maybe uh in some
way taking on the European convention on
human rights in order to deal with a
small boats problem does he have the
numbers in Parliament does he have the
political will within the conservative
party to push through difficult things I
don't yet know that's the essay question
because Sophie if a government can't do
something and isn't governing does it
last I I that's the issue really uh
interesting and that I guess is the big
test we haven't yet had but it does feel
like those things are on the horizon
they're coming up they can't be avoided
at too much longer always really
interesting to talk so I'm going to get
some tea in your Liz truss mug or a
coffee
we'll uh see you next week at always
good to uh talk that's uh our Deputy
political editor at Sam coats well that
is it from safe Ridge on Sunday the take
this morning the podcast will follow
including of course analysis from
Camilla Turner of the telegraph who are
the people who published at that
extraordinary 4 000 word essay from Liz
truss always good to see